also dass 30 news deswegen junge leute
das war die 100 zufolge alle werden
jetzt aber auf mich sein ich hätte mit
allen verscherzt haben
aber egal hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge vom mega
projekt und zwar der hundertsten folge
und ich habe für heute heute heute heute
heute etwas geplant und zwar wir gehen
eben auf den server darauf knickte
megaprojekt in der hockey challenge
angel wir gehen auf den server so die
schilder mussten erstmal ganze jugend
jetzt weiß ich gar nicht was ich machen
will erwarte hier setzt man ganz gut hin
es kann sein dass man inventar ein
bisschen verändert ich hab das ganze im
livestream so ein bisschen vorbereitet
die ich noch nach der aufnahme mit goma
gemacht habe
aber die bleiben da drin die kommen da
raus
irgendwie scheiße diese was euch den
export ansonsten setzen
scheiße alter wartet das ist ein ganz
anderes problem erst mal junge als wir
machen gleich was ich eigentlich planen
wollte ich muss den spot anders
hinsetzen die junge du bist erst mal das
geringste problem hier so jetzt
wo kann ich denn hin packen dass da
nichts bauen würde also ich packte jetzt
erstmal ganz unten in meinen keller und
verschließt irland so wartet das einzige
was ich machen wollte zu 100 folgen hier
900 folgen special mäßig mäßig des ich
setze jetzt einfach hier unten ich hoffe
da passiert sind so dann ab hier hoch
und zwar ruhig glaub ich glaube man hat
schon rad ein bisschen gesehen
die ganze scheiße lohrmann jetzt
verpisst euch erst mal so ich muss auf
jeden fall erstmal dafür beide tonspuren
nicht auf ich muss jetzt meine pennen
gehn
es ist nämlich etwas großes und ich habe
30 minuten dafür gebraucht das zu machen
es hat keiner zugeguckt und als 450
leute oder so relativ wenig eigentlich
deswegen haben wir noch nicht so viel
mitbekommen haben aber schon sehr viele
unter videos von anderen leuten drunter
gesperrt was ich vorhabe
nein es wird keine news eine eines
werden auch nicht sechs sein
das wird was anderes sein und zwar
brauche ich nur noch einen schalter
warte ich muss nämlich vier blöcke davon
weg ein zwei drei vier leute das was ich
mache sind keine keine news park of
phoenix join the game
es ist außerdem ich mach jetzt den
jetlag einfach auf die plätze
es ist außerdem nicht sechs news es ist
was anderes und zwar sind es 30 news ich
habe mir von simon von spark unter
anderem blöd das lab draufgekommen
zweite merkt dass jetzt wahrscheinlich
aber es wegen euch den chat ausgemacht
alle ein paar sachen genau deswegen
wir müssen hoch legen müssen fliegen
fliegen fliegen fliegen fliegen fliegen
fliegen wegen fliegens ländlichen lebens
leben klingler electron lag stand lese
lag noch nicht es läuft noch nicht
direkt noch nicht jetzt legt jetzt legt
alter ok es liegt es leckt ich kann
nichts machen mich bewegt meine maus ich
kann nichts mehr machen
es liegt es liegt es liegt es liegt
alter waren es jetzt 30 oder 40 30
erst kräftig und jetzt ist aber die
stadt weg weil bei kämpfen und ein
bisschen weg gegangen
bei lena ist schon ein bisschen mehr weg
ja natürlich jetzt steht ihm ein
kräftiges crashed ice
und jetzt ist letztes
jetzt ist jetzt ist komplett weg
natürlich ja jetzt ist komplett weg ja
geil
also ich mach mal ganz kurz in karts und
dann sehen uns sofort wieder leute so
leute ich bin wieder back man minecraft
habe ich gerade so oft neu gestartet bis
jetzt endlich wieder funktioniert hat
dass ich überhaupt in dieses mit
bildchen kommenden action das ist alles
am haken das ist übel heftig ich habe
die ränder dissens auf short gestellt
player counter eins drauf wir connecten
jetzt einfach mal zum megaprojekt warten
lol lol lol okay ich bin drauf ich bin
drauf ich bin drauf junge junge junge
junge junge
ok es hart wie sonstwas es hart wie
sonst was ich sehe ca ein frame pro
sekunde
ich versuche alter guckt mal bitte links
also ich habe auf shorts und gar nichts
laufen junge das ist glaube ich
häftlings gewesen cavs wasser zeugs
alter hier ist einfach mal ein riesiger
also ich habe die relativ nahe an die
oberfläche gesetzt aber ich hoffe mal
ihr seht jetzt ein bisschen hier was
junge also ihr seht gerade recht ich
versuche es einfach mal stehen zu
bleiben das thema sondern sollen die
user so ich stelle mir mal so im alter
ich werde euch jetzt einen screenshot
einblenden wird wenig dann nachher
gemacht habt davon
die junge die ganze stadt wird
explodiert die ganze stadt ist weg die
komplette ganze stadt und meine welt
lädt sich nicht mehr aber die komplette
stadt es einfach mal in die luft
gesprengt worden
leute das war die 100 zufolge alle
werden jetzt aber auf mich sein ich
letzte mit allen verscherzt haben
aber egal naja leute alter ist es heftig
junges ist krass naja leute das war die
100 zufolge hiermit übrigens auch mein
austritt aus dem megaprojekt ich hab das
schon lange zeit kein bock mehr drauf
dass man wirklich alles sich jetzt
schießen kann ich bin mit dem diamond
will damit eine gruppe von ein paar
folgen glichen leber gelaufen und ist es
einfach nicht mehr geil also wir lagen
uns alles aufgelaufen dadurch wie sonst
was ist es erfahrung ist nichts
besonderes mehr man stellt sich einmal
zu simon und hat sofort 30 level und das
ist einfach nichts besonderes mehr das
ist irgendwie nicht mehr geil das weise
nicht das finde ich nicht mehr so cool
und na ja also ich habe deswegen jetzt
hier ein bisschen was in der luft
gesprengt um halt den anderen zu zeigen
es geht nicht mehr weiter megaprojekt
ist jetzt beendet und ja hättet mich
ruhig schön in den kommentaren und dann
war es das erst mal vor mir mit dem
megaprojekt schau und offene wieder
wieder sind auch nie wieder szene
megaprojekt trotzdem
herzlichen glückwunsch du bist einer der
kandidaten die ich sehr besonders gern
mag und der das video zu ende geschaut
hat beziehungsweise jetzt noch gerade
dran ist erst mal feiern dich und zwar
das ganze nun troll von mir zu mega
projekt betreut kann man das nicht
nennen
ich habe nämlich die welt im
singleplayer gemacht hat dass alles so
bearbeitet dass es so aussieht als ob es
hakt und ich hoffe es ist ein bisschen
glaubwürdig rüber gekommen ich weiß
selbst mega schlecht war eigentlich aber
ich hatte noch keine zeit mehr bei mir
das eigentlich erst in folge 97
eingefallen dass ich doch so etwas
machen könnte
ab dann kämpf angeschrieben der admin
rechte hat zwar kämpft wollen wir so was
machen es einfach um die welt
runterladen dann auf einen eigenen
server packen und einen jux voll oder
blah blah so wird ihr der sohn ehe das
ist april rechtsmissbrauch und so was
alles das ist nicht so geil und so was
alles also fand gestern nicht sogar habe
ich dann auch realisiert dass es keine
war deswegen habe ich das ganze einfach
versucht so ein bisschen zuschneiden
dass es für euch glaubwürdig war
alle die daumen runter gegeben haben die
verstehen keinen spaß beziehungsweise an
das video nicht zu ende geguckt hassen
mich jetzt auch dass mit dem abschied
wandern troll ich werde weiter dabei
bleiben ich bin laden auf den server ich
kann jetzt zum beispiel mal schreiben
ich sollte vielleicht im chat an machen
deswegen hab ich den job machen wir auf
einmal kommt stark drauf so ich kann es
hier zu schreiben so was also das ist
die stadt die wirklich noch existiert
der schalter hat nix ausgelöst hier hat
nichts gemacht da ist nix drunter da ich
nix damit alles nur vom hier inszeniert
gewesen
jetzt sagt er hat was getrennt aber das
ist letztlich jedenfalls eltern versucht
das euch so ein bisschen laut
glaubwürdig rüberzubringen ist natürlich
nicht das ende vom mega projekt ich
werde dir so lange dabei sein will ich
dabei sein kann und wie lange ich bock
drauf runter scheiße ynet wenn der
wüsste
wenn du mutig nein ich hoffe ich hab's
euch ein bisschen glaubwürdig
rüberbringen können und ich hoffe ihr
war so in dem moment fast alles weg
scheiß dieser pesa und direkt darunter
gegeben die abonniert wenn ihr so ward
und habe ich eigentlich richtig gemacht
aber wenn ihr jetzt auch gerade noch
dran sein dann will ich den treuen leute
die geile sind und das war die
hundertste folge morgen jetzt ganz
normal weiter mit 101 oder morgen oder
übermorgen keine ahnung und dann wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich über
den daumen hoch freuen weil das recht
eine menge menge arbeit und schreibt
meine kommentare ob sie ihr das geglaubt
hat oder nicht und dann sehen uns dann
leben wir wieder